cambodge un drame qui n'en finit pas
nous envoyer ses slogans l'horreur du
pont drion opaque et les otages de
téhéran situation toujours bloquée
l'opinion américaine se durcit la
mutation des universités françaises vers
les disciplines scientifiques
l'exemple de l'université de pau
mais à messieurs bonsoir avant de
développer que ces titres de l'actualité
j'aurais que nous nous arrêtions sur les
hausses de tarifs de l'assurance
automobile qui vous ont tous mis en
alerte car évidemment le dossier
intéresse pratiquement tous les français
alors voici ce que après enquête nous
sommes en mesure de vous dire tout
d'abord pas de modifications avant le
1er janvier et sans doute pas dès le 1er
janvier cela s'échelonnera dans le
courant de l'année prochaine
quant au volume des augmentations la
fédération française des sociétés
d'assurances dit que les premiers
chiffres avancés c'est à dire entre 20
et 40% sont fantaisistes mais il
n'empêche que le taux sera d'importance
est d'ailleurs variable selon les
compagnies alors pourquoi une telle
accélération pour comprendre jean-claude
allanic est allé enquêter dans un gars
est un véritable coup de massue que vont
subir les automobilistes parce qu'ils
paieront en 1981 leurs nouvelles primes
d'assurance en moyenne l'augmentation
sera d'au moins 15%
mais comme il ya désormais
libéralisation des prix et concurrence
entre les compagnies et les mutuelles
bien sûr les tarifs vont être différents
selon les compagnies sont les mutuelles
et dans certains cas certains
automobilistes devront payer 20% plus
cher quelquefois même 25% plus cher pour
bien sûr on peut s'en étonner car c'est
bien supérieur à l'augmentation du coût
de la vie et c'est étonnant et partagée
également par les experts en automobile
les experts qui sont chargés d'évaluer
et de contrôler le montant des
réparations lorsque vous avez un
accident pour comprendre l'augmentation
des primes d'assurances il faut savoir
que ces compagnies d'assurance sont
concernés par trois grands chapitres le
premier les salaires et les frais
généraux
on peut dire qu'il y aura là une
augmentation certainement quittant le
top du sport ce deuxième chapitre le
coût des dommages corporels
alors dans ce domaine 12% aussi
d'augmentation 10 à 12 pour ce troisième
chapitre de dommages matériels les
dommages matériels
nous pouvons dire sûrement que la main
d'oeuvre augmentera de tous pour cent et
le fourniture de plus de 20%
c'est donc du côté des réparateurs et du
côté des fabricants de pièces détachées
qu'on trouve l'explication de la hausse
des assurances
en ce qui concerne les temps de
réparation c'est un départ à sion sont
larges les experts dix ans
officiellement dénonce quant aux
fournitures
on peut dire que le blé le pôle fille
détenus par des constructeurs et par
voie de conséquence directe le facteur
important des augmentations du prix du
coup de dommages matériels de toute
façon que ce soit la faute aux
constructeurs aux réparateurs ou à
l'assureur il vous faudra payer car
l'assurance est obligatoire mais sachez
que si vous trouvez votre prime
d'assurance bien trop élevée l'année
prochaine vous avez une solution
vous pouvez changer d'assureur vous
disposez pour cela d'un délai de quinze
jours après la réception des nouveaux
tarifs dans le même domaine de
l'information pratique tout d'abord ne
vous étonnez pas si votre courrier a
pris un peu de retard sa distribution a
été gêné par la grève des aiguilleurs du
ciel une grève qui s'est poursuivie
aujourd'hui encore et qui devrait se
poursuivre la semaine prochaine
enfin sachez que les chefs d'entreprise
pousse des hauts cris ils reçoivent en
ce moment le relevé de leur taxe
professionnelle pour 79
elle a augmenté 30% par rapport à l'an
passé certains disent même parfois 50%
le cnps inquiète et demande donc la
suppression de cette taxe
en ce jour anniversaire de la mort du
général de gaulle la plupart de ceux qui
l'ont aimée ou estimé ont surtout pensé
à sa femme yvonne milan bière cet après
midi au val de grâce
selon ses dernières volontés aucune
personnalité n'assistera de mme après
midi à ses obsèques qui doivent rester
strictement familial ça se passera bien
sûr à colombey-les-deux-églises madame
de gaulle a été associée à son mari au
cours de l'homélie prononcée ce matin en
l'église de colombes et nous étions dans
le deuil
notre peine s'est encore agrandie a dit
l'abbé calmels ce après la messe les
compagnons de la libération se sont
recueillis devant la tombe blanche
on repose le général et sa fille anne
enfin les gaullistes ont voulu rendre un
dernier hommage devant le mémorial une
croix de lorraine de granit rose
érigé sur la colline haut de ses 43 m
elle est visible de la boisserie dont le
portail est restée fermée aujourd'hui
il y a neuf ans le général s'est assis à
une table de jeu dans la bibliothèque
pour faire une réussite
en regardant la télévision il s'affaissa
brutalement peu après 19h politique
violent réquisitoire du rpr ce mot de
pierre charpy dans la lettre la nation
flow république mondaine tuera la
république tout court et puis surtout ce
propos de maurice couve de murville dans
le figaro qui évoquait précisément le
neuvième anniversaire de la mort du
général de gaulle il ne reconnaîtrait
pas la france aujourd'hui on assiste à
une incroyable dégradation des moeurs
politiques
quant au socialiste georges fillioud il
a estimé que dans la sphère boulin
georges marchais donne est un sérieux
coup de main à giscard
rude journée pour le nouveau ministre du
travail une visite à matignon ce matin
une à l'elysée cette après midi et
surtout l'ouverture de tous les dossiers
de l'heure coincé par un embouteillage
est arrivé à pied chez raymond barre et
c'est là que vous allez faire
connaissance avec lui la seule chose que
je puisse vous dire dès aujourd'hui
c'est naturellement je m'efforcerai de
et de se développer si je puis la
politique de dialogue et de concertation
ce qui a été celle de mes prédécesseurs
et et notamment de robert boulin dont je
ne jette pas m'empêcher d'évoquer à
l'instant l'image est là et la
disparition tragique
vous avez dialogue social concertation
sont deux éléments parmi d'autres d'un
édifice qui s'appelle la participation
vous souvenez peut-être que ça et penner
dernier souci du général de gaulle
je me réjouis que cela soit est demeuré
celui du président de la république et
celui du premier ministre et puis déjà
la cfdt et force ouvrière demande
l'intervention du nouveau ministre dans
le conflit très dur de l'usiné alstom de
belfort où aujourd'hui l'atmosphère
était très tendue demain devrait être
une journée décisive les affaires du
monde maintenance tout d'abord pendant
que jimmy carter se débat dans les
problèmes d'iraniens dont nous allons
parler tout à l'heure son épouse
rosalynn elle visité deux camps de
réfugiés cambodgiens en thaïlande le
plus impressionnant étant celui de saké
au à une cinquantaine de kilomètres de
la frontière cambodgienne y ait là bas
quelques trente mille réfugiés il le
reportage que nous n'aurons pas de
rester philippe chatenet et
jean-françois renou est l'un des plus
bouleversants que nous ayons jamais reçu
quand nous l'avons visionnée ce matin il
été si terrible qui nous avons été
obligés de couper de nombreuses années
bon autant je crois qu'il faut que vous
voyez c'est beaucoup plus qu'un cris des
larmes ça quéau
denard span son élan
ce sont les toutes premières images que
nous ayons tourné à saké au dès notre
arrivée au camp dans la première tente
visiter une jeune fille est morte sous
nos yeux
sous les yeux des médecins impuissants
la mort ici est une chose si fréquent
psy normal qu'elle n'est qu'une
tristesse une horreur fugitive il en
meurt tellement à saké au chaque matin
les morts de la nuit que l'on a déposé
dans une tente sont entassés dans un
autobus pour être emmenés ailleurs à une
fosse commune
ces corps sont ceux de gens qui ont
survécu à des années de terreur au
cambodge à des mois de suite et perdu
sans nourriture sans médicaments et puis
quelques heures ou quelques jours après
avoir réussi à échapper à l'enfer avoir
enfin atteint le sanctuaire de la
thaïlande
ils sont morts sous les regards
indifférents dix vivant on entasse les
corps comme des sacs des hommes des
femmes est tellement d'enfants
plus rien ne semble émouvoir ceux qui
ont survécu qui se pressent autour pour
voir emmener les cadavres ici la mort
est devenu une distraction un spectacle
elle s'appelle dominique angotti
elle a 28 ans elle est médecin
elle est arrivée de france avec une
équipe de médecins sans frontières pour
secourir les réfugiés du cambodge depuis
deux semaines ici elle se bat contre la
mort avec des moyens suffisants
elle doit faire face à une accumulation
de maladie non la malnutrition la
malaria la tuberculose des abcès ne sont
que les plus fréquents
son domaine le voici c'est la tante
numéro 4 de ce que l'on appelle sans
ironie consciente l'hôpital du camp de
saké au avec un autre médecin deux
infirmières et des aides soignants khmer
elle s'occupe de 120 malades d'ekali
libéré par une guérison ou par une mort
un autre malade est admis qui je
suspecte une couverture du bonheur
il arrivera du cambodge
il a passé cinq mois dans la forêt et
une toux depuis cinq mois mais
malheureusement j'ai pas les moyens pour
dépister
mike leigh et encore on n'a pas non plus
les moyens de le traiter
il a beaucoup qui s'en sortiront mais
les plus mal son man malheureusement les
premiers jours on perdait 4 5 6 me
cimade partant ok non plus de maintenant
maintenant est vraiment les affronter
c'est pas très brillant mais c'est moins
désespérant pour les réfugiés au
contraire 70 cet hôpital est un lieu où
renaît l'espoir
beaucoup de malades n'ont pas vu un
médecin n'ont reçu aucun soin pendant
les cinq ans du régime khmer rouge
au delà des blessures et des maladies
il y a aussi les traumatismes psychiques
chez certains réfugiés par exemple
l'esprit est mort même si le corps a
survécu là aussi dominique et les autres
volontaires luttent sans cesse avec pour
arme un sourire une caresse une présence
constante depuis dix jours dit dominique
il s'est produit une transformation
étonnante ces réfugiés ont réappris à
sourire en même temps qu'ils ont
réappris à espérer indiqué il est très
gravement malade pendant quinze jours et
il pense qui va mouiller mais par la
chance
les médecins français a mené de lens et
caen et le sagne maintenant il faut
repenser il ne m'a plu et maintenant
pour d'autres il est trop tard parfois
le corps tout simplement a trop souffert
et rope atteint parfois l'esprit lâche
prise
la volonté farouche de survivre qui les
a soutenus jusqu'à maintenant c'est un
pur cela mourir devient alors une
délivrance
quand cette jeune femme dévorée par la
malaria depuis des mois est morte elle
souriait
mimi
mais ça quéau c'est aussi l'avis déjà en
dix jours dans la tente de dominique une
dizaine d'enfants sont nés et alors
qu'au début
dominique raconte que les maires ne
réagissais même pas lorsqu'on leur
montrer leur nouveau né aujourd'hui leur
sourire et celui de toutes les jeunes
mères même si souvent il faut leur
apprendre à l est et leurs enfants
mais je crois que tout commentaire sur
est impudique donc l'iran avec tout
d'abord la situation à l'ambassade
américaine une situation très délicate
sous on a vraiment l'impression que la
première a qu'un seul peut tout faire
exploser ainsi le chargé d'affaires
américain terran se trouve-t-il lui
aussi sous le contrôle des étudiants la
prière de midi devant l'ambassade
américaine à téhéran
le spectacle est devenu quotidien
mais la foule grossit un peu plus chaque
jour ironie du sort les fidèles doivent
tourner dos à l'ambassade pour prier en
direction de la mecque montrant ainsi au
monde que décidément l'amérique et la
république islamique ne vont pas dans la
même direction
cinq fois par jour ici on demande à
allah de ne pas épargner la vie du cha
li celle du président carter bientôt
nous les pendre ont tous les deux dit la
foule qui soutient la prise d'otages et
encourage les étudiants on entend scandé
remédie lutte et carter tremble les
gardiens de la révolution des hommes de
l'ayatollah khomeini font les cent pas
sans intervenir et se contente du
maintien de l'ordre autour de
l'ambassade
c'est le signe que le guide suprême ne
veut pas ne peut pas contrer les
extrémistes qui dirige l'opération
mais l'ayatollah khomeini n'est sans
doute pas fâché de pouvoir canaliser ici
les mécontentements et d'avoir trouvé
pour cette foule un bouc émissaire
les états unis et surtout ses otages
comme ce conseiller de l'ambassade
américaine présenté comme un espion à la
foudre qui lui crie yankee go home
les américains rentrez chez vous de
40000 sous le chah les conseillers
américains sont passés à moins d'une
centaine pour être réduit à l'état de
simples aux otages et les extrémistes
aujourd'hui le temps traîner l'iran vers
la rupture totale avec les états unis
dans le bureau de l'ambassadeur
américain
retapisser pour la circonstance avec des
portraits de khomeiny
ils nous ont reçus représentants les
plus durs du mouvement islamique
il affirme pourtant que si l'ayatollah
leur demande de cesser l'opération ils
évacueront l'ambassade mais que si
d'autres pays se conduisent comme
l'amérique leurs chancelleries seront
aussi occupé enfin ils affirment que
leur enquête
établir à qui des 60 otages entre leurs
mains sont les vrais espions
mais quelle que soit l'issue de
l'opération
c'est surtout le pouvoir en iran qu'elle
aura touché
il aura donc suffi de cette prise
d'otages ici à l'ambassade américaine
pour fissurer le nouveau régime iranien
le résultat aujourd'hui est celui ci
renforcement de la tendance dure du
mouvement religieux
on a trouvé des éléments ici encore plus
dur que les hommes de l'ayatollah
khomeini des gens qui demandent
carrément que l'iran rompe ses relations
diplomatiques avec les états unis et
même ferme le robinet du pétrole à
l'amérique et pendre haut et court
carter et le shah d'iran
l'autre résultat de cette opération
c'est la mise à l'écart des civils après
la démission forcée du gouvernement bart
goor et le renforcement du conseil de la
révolution islamique
car qui d'autre osera à présent former
un gouvernement
face aux dictats de ces extrémistes
oui cela dit un homme peut peut-être
contribuer à débloquer la situation
c'est l'un des rares qui soient un peu
écoutés de l'ayatollah khomeini il
s'appelle bannissent abril
il a obtenu de l'imam le droit de se
rendre à l'ambassade américaine cet
homme vous le connaissez il était notre
invité aux dossiers de l'écran il ya dix
jours
écouter ce qu'ils nous disaient lorsque
joseph pasteur évoqué devant lui la
notion de clémence et de pardon dans le
coran
un pays après cinq ans 50 du régime
pahlavi corrompu prendre le massacre
condamnation à bord torture libérait
tout un coût et demande lui un ennemi
qui peut rien faire à sa disposition
combien de morts imaginable il s'il n'y
avait pas et spiritualité de khomeiny et
de licha vous regardez 400 condamnait
fait un aspect ou d'oublier cette
réalité que quelque chose après n'est le
sentiment de vengeance de ce peuple qui
était victime en prime est de 100
ce sentiment de vengeance toute cette
affaire embarrasse bien je vous disais
le président carter qui a été obligé
d'annuler d'extrême justesse son voyage
au canada et qui voit une fraction
croissante de son opinion se dresser
contre les iraniens ainsi un avions
d'iranair at il été interdit
d'atterrissage new york et des contre
manifestations ont succédé aux
manifestations anti xa plaque séguy à
washington ne comprend pas que la nation
la plus forte du monde trop réduite à la
puissance totale
enfin des accords de rue après la
communauté iranienne
une foule irrité a toujours ses avions
iraniens ne se pose plus je sers plus
passer les bateaux en partance pour nice
le public américain réclame d'autre part
l'expulsion s'est usé iranienne est né
sait que la route est à kameni il faut
repousser par le gouvernement américain
au nom de la liberté l'exception faire
mais surtout éviter une catastrophe à
terre
à l'autre que nous sommes américains a
suspendu ses livraisons à l'iran de
pièces détachées pour équipements
militaires
levaï ira-t-il imiter l'exemple de bac à
sable selon la fédération des droits de
l'homme 215 personnes ont été tuées par
les militaires et les rois pour la
plupart les victimes sont des jeunes de
17 à 21 ans
ça serait passé le 19 juillet dernier
d'autres sources font état d'une erreur
des militaires qui pensaient avoir
affaire à des chercheurs de diamants
mais ce soir l'ambassade du zaïre nie
formellement toutes ces accusations en
bolivie toujours selon la fédération des
droits de l'homme le récent coup d'état
aurait fait au moins 120 morts plus de
cent personnes sont portées disparues
la biologie à l'honneur l'un vit les
professeurs gros jacob et royer vont
remettre au chef de l'état un rapport
sur les conséquences sociales et
industrielles du développement de la
biologie et ses trois professeurs seront
le soir même les invités de jean pierre
elkabbach et d'alain duhamel point
cartes sur table exceptionnel ce
développement la biologie est vraiment
fantastique depuis quelques années la
biologie est une science relativement
jeune 25 ans et elle trouve ses
applications dans les domaines les plus
variés la médecine bien sûr avec
notamment les manipulations génétiques
dont nous vous avons déjà parlé au cours
la question de temps la médecine mais
aussi l'aquaculture et l'agriculture
philippe dumais en dehors de la médecine
la mer est certainement le lieu où la
bioindustrie aura le plus de débouchés
c'est en effet une des rares industries
où rien n'a changé depuis l'antiquité on
procède toujours à la collecte ou à la
pêche et le poisson et les crustacés
commence à manquer avec un champ
d'application trois fois plus faste que
les terres les possibilités sont énormes
l'élevage ou l'aquaculture des animaux
de la mer en est encore au stade
expérimental en france les problèmes
biologiques c'est à dire de la vie et de
la reproduction de ces animaux ne sont
pas simples à résoudre en tout cas à
faire passer du stade du laboratoire à
l'entreprise industrielle par certains
croisements par certaines manipulations
pas forcément génétique
certains pays comme le japon sont
arrivés à de bons résultats
les expériences pratiquées dans les
laboratoires du qnexa par exemple montre
que l'on met en retard surtout dans les
applications alimentaires ou
énergétiques dans le domaine de
l'agriculture et de l'élevage en
particulier les chercheurs de l'inra ont
déjà réussi certaines prouesses en
particulier pour l'insémination
artificielle
ils sont pratiquement arrivés à
sélectionner le sexe de certains futurs
bébés animaux ou à faire porter par une
mère d'une certaine race un embryon
d'une autre race en phénomène de rejet
dans le domaine des végétaux et du maïs
en particulier les progrès de ces
dernières années ont été spectaculaires
en arrivant introduire dans certaines
variétés la capacité de pousser là où
c'était impossible
les chercheurs sont en train de mettre
au point une méthode qui permettra aux
plantes de fixer l'azoté de l'air par
l'intermédiaire de bactérie associée à
leurs racines
ce sera un énorme avantage puisque l'on
diminuera considérablement l'utilisation
d'engrais
on cherche également à développer la
production de protéines végétales en
faisant pousser des levure capable de
synthétiser ces molécules l'utilisation
de la biomasse en général et la
transformation des déchets agricoles
comme source d'énergie sera un sérieux
atout de la bioindustrie donc la
biologie dans cartes sur table lundi
soir à 20h30 le pull-over rouge le film
de michel drac en partie censure elle la
cour d'appel de paris a ordonné que
certaines séquences du film soient
supprimés notamment les scènes mettent
en cause la famille rambla qui elle vous
en souvenez avait demandé la saisie pure
et simple de ce film un film déjà
interdit à toulon la municipalité de
cette ville a fait ce choix pour éviter
des troubles dans les salles plusieurs
maires de provence ceux de digne
d'aix-en-provence et de carry-le-rouet
envisage également d'interdire ce film
dans leur ville
l'ambassade de belgique à paris toujours
occupé les 21 objecteurs de conscience
français qui réclamait le droit d'asile
à la belgique n'ont pas de réponse pour
l'instant mais les négociations sont
toujours en cours
d'autre part à lyon d'où
jeunes qui avaient envoyé leurs livrets
militaires pour protester contre
l'extension du camp du larzac ont été
condamnés chacun à une amende de 500
francs
et puis le détenu qui s'était coupé
alors payer libre en prison depuis
quatre mois jean piat simoneau n'avait
toujours pas été entendu par le juge
d'instruction
apparemment son geste de protestation
lui a servi puisqu'il a été libéré
aujourd'hui sous contrôle judiciaire
alors maintenant parler du monde
universitaire à propos du budget n'a la
même saunier séité voté aujourd'hui par
les députés
un monde universitaire à dominance de
plus en plus scientifique témoins lé
enquête réalisée par dominique laurie à
l'université de pau une petite
université à peine 5000 étudiants mais
une université qui vous allez le voir ne
manque pas d'idées
ces jeunes preneur sur le plateau du
bénou à quelques 50 kilomètres de pau ne
sont pas des adeptes d'une organisation
prônant le retour à la terre mais les
étudiants en plein travail
ce jeune bavardant sur le campus de
l'université ne sont pas des étudiants
mais des agriculteurs en stage de
formation permanente
ces deux phénomènes symbolise en quelque
sorte
l'évolution de l'université notamment
des universités de province pratiquant
une politique d'ouverture sur la région
premier réflexe est politique
l'insertion de l'université dans
l'appareil économique du sud ouest
45 % du budget annuel de la recherche
est assurée par des contrats passés avec
des organismes privés ou publics
entre l'université et les entreprises le
temps de la méfiance s'est terminé
l'université réalise pour le compte de
la chambre de commerce
un certain nombre d'études économiques
car nous n'avons pas les moyens de nous
payer un service d'études spécialisé à
la chambre de commerce
deuxièmement l'université et la chambre
de commerce travaillent ensemble pour la
création notamment dans les 8 et les
pays de l'adour qui correspond
réellement aux besoins des entreprises
et enfin les laboratoires de
l'université travaille à la demande des
entreprises pour apporter un certain
nombre de services pratiques
mais la grande préoccupation reste
l'emploi les débouchés révélateur de
cette inquiétude le tassement du nombre
d'inscriptions en lettres et en droit
l'augmentation de près de 25% en
sciences augmentation due également au
succès de la nouvelle filière nous en
parlions au début de cette enquête du
diplôme sciences de la nature
un diplôme qui met les étudiants au
contact de la réalité c'est important et
c'est pour ça que vous avez ici
si pour vous faire voir la disposition
réelle de ces cordons pour convoyer des
formes et ensuite on analysera intifada
extra légale et qui constitue une de ces
fonds ici nous formons nos étudiants à
la fois sur les bases mathématiques
chimiques mais aussi sur des bases de
travail de terrain pour que ensuite ils
soient directement compétitif dans un
travail appliqué soit dans le pétrole
est entendue puis nous sommes dans une
région pétrolière dans le centre de la
cre qui est le premier centre européenne
de recherche mais aussi dans
l'agroalimentaire et dans
l'environnement
le but c'est de leur apprendre à
travailler concrètement pour certains à
partie leur origine pour certains y
vivent dans un environnement agricole
mais le but n'est surtout pas de faire
du folklore de style et que l'on le
multi leur apprendre à travailler
concrètement pour ensuite pouvoir
exporter leur savoir faire
partout dans des régions qui sont les
pires les ou ailleurs autre exemple
d'insertion régional l'université ouvre
ses portes au monde rural cinq mois de
stage pendant lesquelles les étudiants
agriculteurs reçoivent un salaire
équivalent au smic
au programme la gestion
l'économie rurale les lois du marché les
sciences du sol le droit ainsi qu'une
langue étrangère des études sanctionnées
par un diplôme il ya la gestion qui est
pour moi vraiment très très importante
et aussi
le niveau commercial sur l'apiculture
qui pose en certains problèmes surtout
avec 22 d'espagne au niveau des marchés
comment il entend que quelle valeur ont
fait par exemple de l'exportation et il
est et il est toujours intéressant de
savoir ce qui se passe entre le
producteur et le consommateur c'est
souvent quelque chose qui nous échappe
cette expérience encore unique en france
a pour résultat les anciens stagiaires
en témoigne un meilleur rendement des
entreprises agricoles nombreuses dans la
région
j'ai travaillé exactement sur la gestion
et la gestion assez approfondies mieux
qu'on avait de bons professeurs
c'est très important pour moi surtout au
jour d'aujourd'hui puisque
l'exploitation agricole n'est pas une
exploitation mais plutôt une entreprise
agricole où il faut surveiller chaque
production parfois essayé d'évoluer au
jour le jour
bref en quelques années l'université a
bien changé l'isolément de la culture un
monde clos replié sur lui même a fait
place à des universités ouvertes sur les
problèmes concrets immédiats et à
contrario c'est une des conséquences de
la crise l'absence de les boucher
le chômage des diplômés ont en quelque
sorte rapprocher le monde universitaire
et étudiants du monde du travail
football sport donc saint-etienne
rencontrera pour les huitièmes de finale
les grecs de salonique harris de
salonique une équipe pas très connu mais
qui a tout même éliminer benfica et les
italiens de pérouges petit désavantage
pour les verts lé match aller aura lieu
le 28 à saint-etienne le match retour
est prévu pour le 12 dessins une femme à
l'académie française un point
d'interrogation qui va sans doute tomber
très vite l'un des derniers temps plus
réservée aux seuls hommes va
vraisemblablement ouvrir ses portes à
marguerite yourcenar une entraide
d'autant plus remarquée que les trois
candidats aux sièges de roger caillois
s'effacerait l'élection est prévue pour
le 6 décembre
l'installer depuis 30 ans dans le
silence de l'île de mon désert quelque
part dans le maine
reste des états unis marguerite
yourcenar âgé maintenant de 76 ans n'a
rien demandé rien sollicité
pourtant le 6 décembre les parts de
l'académie française s'ouvriront devant
elle pour lui donner la place qu'il
attend bien au delà de cette victoire
que représente l'entrée d'une femme dans
un bastion de tout temps réservé aux
hommes
la présence de marguerite yourcenar est
aussi surtout le symbole d'un talent qui
dépasse et balaie toutes les frontières
entre une prétendue écriture féminine et
masculine une présence qui couronnera
enfin une oeuvre immense
déjà dès 1951 avec les mémoires
d'hadrien avec ses traductions des
poètes grecs
elle s'était faite gardienne archiviste
de notre histoire
l'air de rien car marguerite yourcenar
est une femme qui désamorce tous les
grands discours de tous les maux
majuscule mots inutiles dont elle se
méfie elle ne retient que celui de
modestie comme si sa culture infinie la
rendait à chaque fois plus légère plus
indépendant de toutes les modes
d'écriture ou de penser avec ses
souvenirs pieux ses archives du nord sa
chronique familiale qu'elle de
broussailles peu à peu on entre dans un
labyrinthe on ne pourra jamais vraiment
la rencontre et discrète 1,6 face car
pour un individu est intéressant que
dans la perspective du monde un monde
passé présent un monde vivant dont elle
s'est éloignée pour mieux l'imaginer et
nous le restituer en recevant marguerite
yourcenar c'est peut-être ce regard
lointain d'une femme que l'académie
française est prête à recevoir
aujourd'hui comme pour s'ouvrir de
nouveaux horizons
voilà nous arrivons à la fin de ce
journal juste une parenthèse vous avez
été très nombreux
après notre reportage sur les camps de
réfugiés cambodgiens tout à l'heure à
vouloir manifester votre soutien d'une
manière ou d'une autre
et bien voici le l'adresse du comité
national d'entre aide aux réfugiés
indochinois 42 rue de cambronne 75015 à
paris ouriel téléphone et je pense que
ce qui vous intéresse et surtout le ccp
22/100 66 44 des à paris est plus une
information pour les lecteurs de
l'express leurs magazines pour des
raisons de grève ne sortira pas demain
mais probablement lundi ou mardi
la météo maintenant aujourd'hui avec une
diapositive quand même et et terreur
pendant journal dans une petite panne
les pluies qui étaient tombés sur une
grande partie de la france ce sont des
là c'est vers le sud du pays demain vous
allez le voir le temps sera frais et
instable les éclaircies seront plus
belles de la bretagne à l'aquitaine et
il neigera en montagne au dessus de 800
mètres à vos prochains rendez vous avec
la formation sont fixés tout d'abord ce
soir à 22h45 avec avec l'aude
demain samedi ennemis présentée par
jean-claude mains jouées gerols sera
consacrée à la 11è convention de la
bande dessinée participeront à cette
émission les dessinateurs les plus
célèbres reiser cabu franck leplus pour
ne citer qu'eux et puis à 20h pour
trouverez léon zitrone quant à moi je
vous retrouverai avec le plus grand
plaisir
lundi passé une très bonne pas de soi
bonsoir à tous